[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and welcome to another
installment of our weekly anime newscast
as always the links to everything i
talked about are right there in the
description and if you want to recommend
a new story or a video for me to talk
about next week leave it in the comments
now the big story of this week is again
YouTube ad policies and the question
whether YouTube is now going to destroy
your favorite anime youtubers or your
favorite youtuber in general basically
what happened is that recently youtubers
have been phased into a new ad system
created by YouTube and this system
basically Flags certain content as not
suitable for all advertisers this all
stems too from the apocalypse back in
April I believe we're a bunch of
advertisers pulled out of YouTube
altogether because they realize that
certain inappropriate videos with like
racist material we're having ads shown
on them and of course this is only
because these videos slipped through the
cracks
because there are millions and millions
of videos on YouTube so when YouTube
then in order to get these advertisers
back is they gave them an option to opt
out of all content that could be
considered not suitable for all
advertisers so basically anything that
is too mature to vulgar to a sexually
explicit for these big companies to want
to be associated with and the fact is
that your favorite anime youtubers some
of the biggest names in the atitude
community including lost pause the anime
man aki dearest and giga are now being
affected by this policy noble from lost
pause made an emotional video about it
last week the anime man did as well in
which he said that a third of his videos
have been affected aki dearest made a
quick video as well i Saki cook and
other youtubers talking about this on
Twitter so this is a huge thing now for
the YouTube community the YouTube anime
community now here at Anime uproar we've
actually been phased into this new
system a few weeks ago so I can tell you
exactly from personal experience how the
system works basically the vast majority
of advertisers seem to opt out of these
not suitable for all advertiser videos
so what happens is that
your video is deemed not suitable for
all advertisers you've got to be making
something like one tenth of why you
should be making in revenue from if your
video was not flagged as unsuitable so
of course that is obviously a huge
problem for someone trying to make a
living from YouTube and there are two
big problems with this new flagging
system the first is of course censorship
and Joey talked about this at length in
his video essentially YouTube seems to
be saying that if you want to make money
on YouTube you have to be what they call
family-friendly we're not exactly sure
what this means because the system seems
to be working quite randomly you never
know why exactly it's flagging something
as not suitable but essentially if you
want to play it safe let's say you would
have to stop cursing altogether you
would have to stop talking about
sexually explicit content you would have
to perhaps stop talking about violence
as well so I don't know how you can talk
about certain anime like let's say
attack on Titan and so on without
talking about all these things so what
this is why a lot of youtubers and anime
youtubers in particular are upset
because how can you review an itchy
anime how can you review a violent anime
and still be able to make money on your
video so yes essentially this amounts to
censorship and this is a big problem in
my opinion for YouTube because what made
YouTube unique and different from
conventional TV stations is that it was
uncensored is that anyone could make a
video being as blunt as they wanted
talking about things that they wanted to
talk about and actually get an audience
for that
whereas on TV if you're watching a TV
network you know that they're gonna be
very sanitized they want to make sure
that no one criticizes them that no one
files a complaint so they're gonna
anything controversial they're gonna
take it out of the broadcast now you
could say that youtubers who don't care
about making money can still make the
kind of videos they want to make and
that is true however while there are
quality youtubers out there who take
YouTube as just a hobby and not a job
the fact is that if they are working on
YouTube and also have a full-time job
somewhere else they are most likely
gonna be making a lot less videos and
making videos a lot less frequently than
someone who is actually treating YouTube
as a full-time job so those YouTube
creators
do you want to make YouTube their job
and want to bring out regular frequent
content to their fans are in a big
dilemma now do they have to shift their
entire approach completely do they have
to start making completely different
videos in order to become
family-friendly or do they stick to what
they're doing even if they are risking
potentially not being able to make ends
meet and pay their bills the other big
problem is that this new flagging system
doesn't even work properly every single
video that we had flagged on our Channel
and we requested a review for because
you now have the option to request a
review was approved meaning they said
yes the system made a mistake this video
is fine for all advertisers so clearly
something is wrong here and while it is
definitely a good thing that you now
have the option to request a review
because a few weeks ago you didn't even
have that the problem is that each video
when they first come out your
subscribers receive a notification as
soon as the video comes out and then
they watch it so if your video is
falsely flagged as unsuitable for all
advertisers as soon as it comes out for
the first day or two that it takes for
this review to go through you are not
going to be making money so your
subscribers are gonna be watching your
video but you're not gonna be making
money off that video until they approve
the review and that could be two days
later when most of the views on that
video have already been gotten so you're
not making that money back imagine that
you earn a hundred dollars a day at your
9 to 5 job you go in one day you earn a
hundred dollars you go in the next day
you do the same amount of work by your
employer tells you sorry your work was
deemed unsuitable for all customers so
I'm only going to pay you 10 percent of
what I paid you yesterday now you don't
know what they're talking about because
there's nothing wrong with your work so
you request a review and two days later
they get back to you and say yeah
actually you were right there was
nothing wrong with your work however
we're not gonna give you the money that
you would have gotten because it's too
late now those customers that were here
are now gone your viewers on YouTube
that saw the video without ads are gone
so you will not be making that money
back even though you did nothing wrong
and there was nothing wrong with your
video
it was our mistake so yeah this is
definitely a really difficult situation
for any youtuber trying to make them
living on YouTube because especially if
you have a lot of subscribers like a
million subscribers like the anime man
Aki dearest lost pause misty connects
yeah and you upload a video and all your
subscribers get the notification and
watching the first day or two if this
video is flagged even if it was
wrongfully flagged and eventually upon
review they approve it you will not be
making money from your own subscribers
watching your videos so definitely a
really difficult situation we'll see how
it goes maybe YouTube will actually fix
this system I don't know but I will keep
you posted in case there's any sort of
community effort to fight against this
to stand up to this and another non
YouTube news a new OVA ferrari's ero has
just been announced and actually we've
gotten a scene a quick two minutes scene
preview from the OVA link to that is in
the description now in this scene we
basically see everyone hanging out at
the Roswell Manor we see Subaru freaking
out as usual and then it turns out that
he's apparently freaking out because he
has to make a cake anyway looks like
this is gonna be filler however I do
think that this is a good sign for
season two I've said this before but I
definitely think that we zero is both
popular and profitable enough to justify
a second season
the only issue until recently was that
the light novel did not have enough
material for a full season - personally
I'm not caught up on the light novels so
I can't speak to that but according to
my boys Sol Maka's expert opinion the
light novel is just about now ready to
have enough content for a full season -
so perhaps after this OVA we could be
looking at an announcement about a
Reiser season - I don't know I would
definitely like to see a season 2
announcement soon I'm looking forward to
seeing what happens to all these
characters let me know what you think is
season 2 coming soon and if so are you
excited the third season of food Wars is
set to premiere on October 3rd in Japan
and a new ad for the third season has
just been released I know a lot of you
guys were excited about food Wars
getting another season in a previous
video in which I talked about it so you
can check out this add link in the
description and for the first time ever
three men were arrested in Japan for
allegedly hacking into the Weekly Shonen
Jump website and leaked pages of the one
piece manga before that chapter was
released these three men have been
charged with violating Japan's copyright
laws and apparently they have been
profiting with millions of dollars from
these leaks by publishing them on their
own website now we all know how common
spoilers and leaks are in the anime and
manga industry we're getting them all
the time Dragon Ball super spoilers for
the upcoming episodes have been
particularly interesting to many
youtubers here on the platform so let me
know guys what what do you think about
this should these guys be severely
punished or do you think that in this
internet age leaks and spoilers are
bound to happen and there's nothing we
can do about it let me know down below
as you guys might know if you've been
following the channel for a while back a
few months ago we actually had a special
episode of Rand cafe our weekly podcast
that we do every Thursday at 5 p.m.
eastern standard time where we roasted
or critiqued that anime snobs book now
of course that anime snob is an anime
youtuber who was actually kicked off of
YouTube for playing some erotic games
and now he is posting videos to vid me
however I just learned that he actually
started a Kickstarter to help fund the
publication of that book that we
critiqued on Rand cafe the snob actually
claims that he implemented some of my
feedback from that rant cafe episode
into the new version of the book he says
that included more scenes with dumbasses
my favorite character from the book so
yeah if you're interested in checking
out what he's up to I will leave the
link to the Kickstarter in the
description I have to say that the
artwork for the book is has been updated
and looks really good you got Maps you
got anime like characters that look like
I said impressive so yeah we'll see what
happens I want to give a quick thank you
to Salman a Luffy and you Ichiro Amana
for becoming the latest anime uproar
patrons and of course I want to thank
the rest of our patrons including
Gilgamesh third-strike Sinead Oh
Christian floor Urbano T mega and
original ink on top of that I want to
thank all of our past patrons your
support really does mean a lot to us
as I said in the past we are gonna
continue making videos on this channel
anyway because that's what we love to do
but if you want to support our patreon
that will allow us to spend more time
making content instead of working other
jobs on this side so if you want to
check out our patreon link in the
description and my favorite amv for this
week is an MV called stay alive by a
youtuber by the name of dragon fi this
is an epic a MV that features primarily
attack on titan and my hero academia
with just the touch of Dragon Ball super
and I really enjoyed it quite a bit
definitely impressive work by a small
youtubers so be sure to check it out and
show them some love and that is it for
this week guys if you enjoy these videos
be sure to LIKE and subscribe and until
next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]